[Applaus]
[Musik]
wir alle wissen dass die vereinigten
staaten ein massives rassismus problem
haben denn wenn es um den dauerbrenner
rassismus geht sind alle empörten
politiker medien rund um den erdball auf
kein anderes land der welt ist so stark
fixiert wie auf die usa
und während die westliche supermacht
ständig unter beobachtung der
weltöffentlichkeit steht und mit jedem
noch so kleines fall von diskriminierung
frenetische empörung stürme oder gar
wellen gewalttätige ausschreitungen
vermeintliche antirassisten auslöst
gehen rassistische exzesse an anderen
orten dieser welt in ganzen getöse unter
angst vor corona wie aus schwarzer
werden in china aus mit donna spielen
verband und aus ihren häusern vertrieben
du findest das kratzt dann warte was
noch alles kommt denn das ist nur ein
kleines beispiel von sehr vielen noch
viel krasser hat die mit rabatt ist dass
rassismus ein absolut globales phänomen
ist bei dem alle arten von rassen sowohl
auf der ober als auch auf der täterseite
vertreten sind von indien über wander
und simbabwe bis china und an dieser
stelle fragt sich vielleicht warum wir
uns von all diesen ländern mit massiven
rassismus probleme in diesem video
ausgerechnet auf china konzentrieren
wollen nun aus zwei gründen der erste
ist dass china in den letzten monaten
eine enorme antirassismus tatort
aufgefahren hat um unter diesem vorwand
seine außenpolitische agenda
voranzutreiben wäre der korona
währungskrise wurde jedes mal wenn ein
land die grenzen zum china schloss
dieses land beschuldigt rassistisch zu
sein wenn er folgendes
[Musik]
chinas gesamter in israel vergleicht
währungs reiseverbote mit holocaust doch
gerade wenn es um rassismus geht es
china wahrlich das allerletzte land
welches uns darüber belehren könnte
denn ohne viele suchen zu müssen sind
wie zum beispiel auf folgenden werbespot
gestoßen der von noch vier jahren im
staatlich kontrollierten chinesischen
sie lief
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt mag vielleicht einwenden das ist
in china doch gar nicht so viele
schwarze gebe reden wir wirklich von
einer unterdrückten minderheit haben
chinesen wirklich ein problem mit
menschen dunkler hautfarbe nun die
wahrheit ist ja aber das ist noch nicht
mal die schlimmste ausprägung des
chinesischen rassismus diese daten sind
weiß ganz und gar nicht die einzigen
rassisten genauso wie schwarz sind nicht
die einzigen opfer von rassismus sind in
wirklichkeit sind die größte und am
meisten unterdrückte minderheit der welt
weder schwarz noch nach kinos sondern
die uiguren und wenn es nicht china so
was wie eine recht auf freie
meinungsäusserung geben würde hätte eine
bewegung namens fribourg leid matters
alle hände voll zu tun
ihr glaubt mir nicht da seht euch mal
folgendes ab
das schicksal der urkomischen muslime in
china von umerziehungslager zur
zwangsarbeit und das ist führt uns
direkt zum zweiten grund warum wir
dieses video machen was durch als jede
werden hat in den mainstream medien kaum
beachtung gefunden obwohl die
unglaublichen taten der chinesischen
regierung selbst das ehemalige brutale
apartheid regime in südafrika in den
schatten stellen
tatsächlich waren sogar wie er hat
gesagt wenn man ziemlich davon
überrascht was bei der recherche zu
diesem video alles zum vorschein kam
und je mehr details will entdeckten bist
du schrecklich wir uns das ganze ausmaß
dieses menschheitsverbrechen damit ihr
euch eine vorstellung machen könnte
wovon ich spreche
chinas regierung erkennt offiziell 56
ethnische gruppen innerhalb seines
riesenreiches an aber nur eine dieser
ethnischen gruppen die han repräsentiert
mehr als 90 prozent der bevölkerung
werde ich 65 minderheiten zusammen
weniger als zehn prozent ausmachen
aber was bedeutet das sieht doch ganz so
aus dass auch das kommunistische regime
ethnische vielfalt und
minderheitenrechte respektiert nun das
problem ist ja und nein ein chinesischer
staatsbürger muss in seinem
personalausweis vermerkt haben welcher
ethnie oder minderheit sie oder er
angehört und das ist nicht irgendeine
formalität denn das was im formularfeld
entsteht kann sehr sehr schwerwiegende
konsequenzen für einen haben in der
autonomen region xinjiang zum beispiel
der einzigen region in der die
uigurische bevölkerung in der mehrheit
ist haben die behörden seit 2000 17
bilder fingerabdrücke ihres aufnahmen
dna und biometrische daten von jedem
einzelnen bewohner der region genommen
natürlich wurde kein einziger einwohner
stehen die angst nach sowas wie seinem
einverständnis gefragt nun im grunde
kulturschock plänen zum beispiel seine
dna-probe aufzugeben allerdings mussten
dann alle diejenigen welche nicht
freiwillig an der totalen durchleuchtung
ihrer selbst teilnehmen wollten
mit ein paar konstruktiven und
gesellschaftlichen nachteilen rechnen
die da wären nun man hat dann zum
beispiel keinen zugang zu grundlegenden
amtlichen dokumenten ach ja unseren kann
wegen illoyalität gegenüber den regie
angeklagt werden und wenn das passiert
dass man dann an einem
erziehungsprogramm
alle nehmen ja und das bedeutet im
grunde dass china eine totalitäre
diktatur ist in welcher das regime seine
interessen knallhart gegenüber seinen
untertanen durchsetzt überrascht
natürlich kaum jemanden handelt es sich
aber tatsächlich auch um unterdrückung
die auf rassismus basiert diese
vergleichen viele
menschenrechtsorganisationen chinas
umgang mit den figuren mit dem umgang
der nazis mit juden und um eines
klarzustellen wir sprechen hier nicht
von gruppen gefährlicher neoliberale
china sondern von organisationen wie
human rights watch und dem europäischen
parlament sind die rassismus-vorwürfe
gegen peking also begründet wird der
rassismus wirklich vom kommunistischen
regime china selbst genährt und
betrieben und wenn ja warum wer ist am
stärksten davon betroffen
heute werden wir alle diese fragen
beantworten und die immer sind es dabei
zunächst der blick in die geschichte
[Musik]
die auserwählte rasse
es wird dich vielleicht überraschen wenn
ich dir sage dass 30 prozent der
chinesischen bevölkerung keine mandarin
sprechen wenn wir an china denkt neigen
auch dazu uns ein gigantisches super
homogenes land vorzustellen in dem alle
gleich sind alle top chinesen sprechen
anderen und folgen chinesischen
traditionen im grunde also ein ganz
anderes bild als der rest von europa mit
seinen vielen völkern kulturen und
sprachen im kopf herumtragen
nun ist das aber ganz und gar nicht
erfüllt das heutige china ist ein land
mit fast 1,4 milliarden menschen das ist
schon mal doppelt so viel wie ganz
europa und es ist ein relativ junges
land zumindest was seine heutigen
grenzen und sein politisches system
angeht es gibt ganze regionen deren
kulturelles erbe nichts mit chinesischer
kultur oder irgendwas was die rehwild zu
tun haben und natürlich meinen damit
hauptsächlich zwei regionen tibets und
die region shin chan
dort sind die han-chinesen in der
minderheit und fast die gesamte
bevölkerung spricht eigene lokale
sprachen nur damit du weißt in china
werden mehr als 300 verschiedene
sprachen gesprochen und damit sind nicht
einfach nur unterschiedliche dialekte
gemeint wir reden hier von sprachen die
in vielen fällen noch nicht einmal
miteinander verwandt sind die uigurische
sprache ist eines dieser beispiele
sie verwendet keine chinesischen
schriftzeichen sondern eine adaption des
arabischen alphabets in hongkong wird
kantonesisch gesprochen und das
mitmachen in etwa so viel zu tun haben
wie spanisch mit russisch dessen
ungeachtet ist china als politische
realität nicht erst seit dem kommunismus
sondern seit jeher davon besessen alles
zu zentralisieren und zu
vereinheitlichen
genau genommen fing all dies schon im
dritten jahrhundert vor christus an und
erreichte etwa 200 jahre später während
des zahlreiches seinen höhepunkt und
jetzt hast du dich vielleicht wer sind
eigentlich diese hans die han chinesen
die sich überall breit machen und von
denen immer die rede ist nur im grunde
handelt es sich um so was die
vorstellung vom typischen chinesen
das fängt beim typisch chinesischen
gesichtszügen an
und natürlich muss ein hahn man darin
sprechen sie repräsentieren die
stereotype chinesische kultur und
tradition im grunde wurde mit dem bild
des modellhaften haben etwas geschaffen
was analog in deutschland mal mit dem
bild des arias erreicht werden sollte
ein rassisch reines idealbild des volks
angehörigen und untertags welches ganz
europa und schließlich die ganze welt
dominieren sollte nun wie wir alle
wissen
scheiterte in europa dieses pervers
größenwahnsinnige sozialexperiment
zugibt dass man das verlief die
geschichte jedoch im riesenreich china
wir befinden uns mittlerweile im jahr
2021 ganz china wird zu 92 prozent von
den han dominiert ganz china
nein denn zwei von unbeugsamen völker in
bewohnte dörfer regionen hört nicht auf
widerstand zu leisten
tibet und china in tibet machen die
haben nur acht prozent der bevölkerung
aus und entschieden sie haben etwas über
38 grad aber auch in diesen regionen
halten und die haben auch historisch
gesehen allem acht positionen inne
denn sie waren die kolonialherren lange
zeit jedoch hatten diese kein großes
interesse an einer drastischen umvolkung
doch im jahr 1949 war nur fünf prozent
der bevölkerung scheint japan
denn das gleichgewicht zwischen den
chinesischen ethnien und den eroberten
völkern war mehr oder weniger leicht zu
halten
man brauchte in den kolonien keine
größeren anteile an haben denn
schließlich sei china ein vorher alles
land mit einem hierarchischen
politischen system in dem jeder eine
klare vorstellung von seiner sozialen
rolle im zwanzigsten jahrhundert
änderten sich die dinge aber schlagartig
da schlafen die chinesische drache
erwartet und fand sich mit einem
neuzeitlichen problem konfrontiert wie
bauen wir einen modernen nationalstaat
mit soviel völkern auf die uns als
invasoren sehen die lösung des ersten
präsidenten der republik china war
einfach wir werden den minderheiten
sagen dass wir nicht nur freunde sind
sondern dass wir alle den gleichen
ursprung haben das hanreich von vor mehr
als 2000 jahren und sie machten sich
einfach daran diesen teil der geschichte
ist so brachial umzuschreiben als wäre
sie die autoren einer billigen
telenovela
wir müssen unseren streik vorbei legen
weil ich gerade herausgefunden habe dass
wir in wahrheit gesucht sind naja
eigentlich keine so schlechte idee einen
teufelskreis aus alten feindseligkeiten
mit hilfe einer legende zu durchbrechen
oder wo ist also das problem nun mal
ganz davon abgesehen dass es sich um
eine historische lüge handelt und die
menschen die es genau wissen
städte eben auch diese legende die
herren als die großen lieblings söhne in
der großen chinesischen familie da und
in der zwischenzeit mussten sich die
minderheiten neu erfinden um sich die
zuneigung der mond republik zu verdienen
dann jedoch kam mao tse tung und
erkannte dass es zeit ist den aufbau
eines ganzen volkes auf eine
3 art voranzutreiben er ist die
chinesischen schriftzeichen vereinfachen
und das erlernen der gemeinsamen sprache
zu erleichtern und erschließt die
verdorbenen hansen von ihrem protest
denn die absolute vorherrschaft der hand
war auf politischer und sozialer ebene
mittlerweile so groß geworden dass sogar
die chinesische verfassung den hand
tourismus als betrug ansehen
im kampf zur wahrung der einheit der
nationalitäten ist es notwendig den
chauvinismus der großen nation vor allem
den chauvinismus der hahn sowie den
lokalen nationalen chauvinismus zu
bekämpfen
auszug aus der präambel der chinesischen
verfassung während die herren also nun
von ihrem hohen sockel runterkommen
mussten wurden durch die neue verfassung
sogar einige kulturelle soziale und
sprachliche rechte der ethnischen
minderheiten anerkannt in einigen fällen
mussten sie sogar die privilegien
erscheinen wäre die han chinesen zum
beispiel die ein-kind-politik einhalten
mussten konnten die minderheit mit zwei
oder sogar drei kinder haben und du
denkst ist wahrscheinlich ist doch alles
in butter warum gibt es dieses video
endlich mal ein fall in dem kommunisten
auch zu denen von ihnen proklamierten
werten der gleichheit und brüderlichkeit
stehen und weg an dieser stelle und
vertriebenen mit erhalten warum nun die
immer steckt der teufel im detail und
diese details nehmen wir jetzt mal etwas
genauer unter die lupe
kein land der hipster im zweiten
jahrzehnt des 21 jahrhunderts kam es in
europa und amerika durch irgendeinen
ironischen riss im raum-zeit-kontinuum
dazu dass es nach mehr als 100 jahren
unter relativ jungen männern wieder in
mode kam aberwitzige werte zu tragen in
der pflege sind mehr zeit und geld
investieren als in die erziehung ihrer
zukünftigen kinder an den männern im
uigurischen autonomen gebiets den
schaden den diese mode jedoch vollkommen
vorbei nicht weil es nicht um ein
paralleluniversum handeln würde sondern
weil eine figur mit left bad ein
gewaltiges problem mit der staatsmacht
bekommen würde warum weil ein solcher
barth von der regierung als indiz dafür
gewertet werden würde dass er sich
höchstwahrscheinlich um einen radikalen
extremisten handelt und wie du
wahrscheinlich schon erraten hast geht
es der kommunistischen partei chinas kpc
hierbei natürlich nicht um
gemeingefährliche hipster sondern um
moslems chinas uiguren inhaftiert wegen
bettensteuern und internet surfen
wir sprechen also nicht nur über werte
sondern auch bei frauen die ihren kopf
bedecken personen die religiöse riten
praktizieren oder ausländische websites
besuchen und das ist noch nicht das ende
der veranstaltung man kann sogar für den
besuch von verwandten außerhalb chinas
verhaftet werden oder für den kauf von
lebensmitteln mit einem halal etikett
auch ein blinder mit krückstock sieht
also sofort dass die meisten diese
einschränkungen irgendwie was mit dem
islam zu tun haben sie sind genau darauf
ausgelegt die bedeutung dieser religion
in der chinesischen gesellschaften
reduzieren und die kbc macht daraus auch
da keinen hehl
chinas westliche region shin chan hat
berufsbildungszentrum für muslimische
uiguren gesetzlich vorgeschrieben
inmitten wachsender internationaler
besorgnis über das massenhafte
verschwinden von menschen aus der region
shenyang behauptet dass die zentren den
extremismus durch gedanken
transformation bekämpft werden
der danken transformationen das klingt
schon ganz wie aus orwells 1984 oder
axel ist schöner neuer welt an sofia
dystopische rhetorik kommt selbst heiko
maas netzwerk durchsetzungs gesetz nicht
heran
aber natürlich haben wir es hier mit
einer diktatur zu tun viele dinge die in
einem demokratischen land als vollkommen
inakzeptabel gelten würden sind in china
nun mal alltäglich außerdem dass du dich
ist wahrscheinlich
wie konnte es überhaupt so weit kommen
haben wir nicht gerade gesagt dass china
vielfalt akzeptiert und die kulturellen
sprachlichen und religiösen rechte
dieser minderheiten durch seine
verfassung garantiert nun lasst uns für
einen moment in der zeit zurückreisen
und über die verfasserin kommunistischer
staaten zu sprechen
manche von euch die vielleicht so wie
ich selbst noch eine kommunistisches
regime miterlebt haben werden doch aus
eigener erfahrung wissen was sind
starten welche in die totalität
abgedriftet sind viele ganz toll klingen
die rechte der jura auf dem papier
stehen
de facto jedoch für den menschen in
diesen systemen ganz andere regeln
gelten die zeigen dass verfassungen der
ddr des sozialistischen polen oder der
cssr waren schließlich auch mehr oder
weniger nur augenwischerei
in china kommt da aber noch etwas
anderes hinzu denn einerseits erkennt
die verfassung von 1982 die ethnische
vielfalt die rechte der minderheiten und
das recht aller bürger an sich ihrer
religiösen überzeugung zu bekennen aber
auf der anderen seite ist es
ausdrücklich verboten und seine religion
zu nutzen um die einheit unter den
chinesischen nationalitäten zu gefährden
und dieser passus kann in der praxis
dame vollkommen nach dem gutdünken der
herren ganz oben ausgelegt werden du
könntest also zum beispiel in china
sagen ich bin gut ist und es würde dir
nichts passiert aber wenn du lange redet
übertroffen würdest wäre die mindestens
eine unvergessliche nacht hinter gittern
garantiert in der tat verbietet das
regime jede art von nationalistischen
bewegungen außerdem hat
hinzu kommt dass es außerdem noch eine
ganze reihe von gesetzen und
verordnungen gibt die der verfassung
selbst widersprechen denn auch wenn
minderheiten auf dem papier der
verfassung das recht haben in ihren
eigenen sprachen unterrichtet zu werden
werde in den letzten jahren reihenweise
dekrete erlassen welche den unterricht
in einigen regionen nur einem anderen
erlauben und wolltest du natürlich
einwenden dass man nichts
verfassungskonformer gesetze und
vorschriften doch vor einem
verfassungsgericht für nichtig erklären
lassen könnte aber würdest du es auch
wagen die chinesische regierung fort
ihren eigenen gerichten anzuprangern und
einen solchen prozess gegen den
allmächtigen staat bis zur höchsten
instanz durchzustehen ich glaube wir
alle kennen die antwort darauf denn mit
recht düsterer macht wir es hier zu tun
haben sollte uns allen klar werden wenn
wir uns folgendes vor augen führen
wissenschaftler debattieren über chinas
gesetz zur sterilisation von trägern
genetischer defekte hier geht es nicht
nur um politische oder kulturelle recht
nein hier geht ist uns knallhart
existenzielle und wenn du vorhin
vielleicht dachte dass ich beim
vergleich zwischen der chinesischen hand
ideologie und den nazi kult eine aria
herrenrasse übertrieben habe und heute
gut zu mir alle haben ja von der ein
kind politik gehört diese waffe und 1979
bis 2015 in kraft
weniger bekannt ist jedoch ein anderes
gesetz dass bestimmte paare dazu zwingt
potenziellen nachwuchs zu treiben oder
sich sogar sterilisieren zu lassen das
sogenannte mutter kind gesundheitsgesetz
von 1994 passiert zunächst auf einer
brutalen auslegung der volksgesundheit
grundsätzlich gilt wenn ein paar
irgendeine art von vererbter
körperlicher oder geistiger krankheit
hat darf er sich nicht fortpflanzen
heiraten zu können muss man also
nachweisen was man sterilisiert wurde
das gleichgesetzt spricht auch von
defekten töten in diesem fall wird der
abbruch der schwangerschaft empfohlen
und du christ ihr wahrscheinlich gut
vorstellen wie solche empfehlungen in
einer totalitären gesellschaft mit
knallharten social scoring und
konzentrationslagern es wird gedanken
transformation zu verstehen sind gut
inzwischen werden einige von euch
vielleicht denken das ist alles doch gar
nicht wahr sein kann
china ist doch kein total abgestimmtes
land wie nordkorea und übertreibt doch
maßlos sowas kann es heute doch nicht
mehr geben das würden sich doch die
menschen in einem mittlerweile so
modernen land wie china nicht gefallen
lassen
außerdem würde das alles ja einen
aufschrei in der weltöffentlichkeit
hervorrufen
aber irgendwann alles die quote über
china nach ohne dich von den
schnellzügen und der ganzen technischen
modernisierung des landes blenden zu
lassen
technischer fortschritt führt nämlich
ganz und gar nicht automatisch zu
gesellschaftlichem fortschritt und
gerade wir in deutschland sollten dies
besonders gut wissen haben die nazis
denn auch nicht mit technischen
superlativen gepasst während sie
gleichzeitig den staat und die
gesellschaft sowie jede art von
aufklärung und unmenschlichkeit in einem
albtraumhaften abgrund in
millionenfaches unglück wissen diese
zwei dinge
technischer fortschritt und
gesellschaftlicher rückschritt schließen
sich also ganz und gar nicht aus
übrigens auch nicht in den westlichen
ländern in denen die konzerne gerade
menschen und gesellschaft mit ständig
wachsendem druck ihren eigenen
partikulare vorstellungen
reden wir darüber hinaus über einen
traditionell bereits sehr nicht
individualistisch ist das heißt extrem
kollektivistische sand ein land also
indem man davon ausgeht dass der
einzelne vor allem mit dem gemeinwohl
verpflichtet die interessen und das
glück des individuums da ist ein bürger
also unter so gut wie allen umständen
den interessen des staates unterzuordnen
sind im rahmen dieser logik sind viel
dazu vorgeschriebene für uns derzeit
noch unvorstellbaren dinge vollkommen
inkonsistent mit der gesellschaftlichen
philosophie chinas niemand kann daher
sagen dass china sich selbst nicht treu
ist das kollektive wissen muss mit sehr
vielen problemen behaftet ist wäre aber
ein thema für ein ganz eigenes video der
die politischen und gesellschaftlichen
fronten der gegenwart und zukunft
verlaufen nicht wie uns ständig
eingetrichtert wird zwischen den
abstrakten kampfbegriffen links und
rechts sondern eben zwischen den
kollektivistisch und den individualisten
wenn individualismus bedeutet dass ich
den gesamtinteressen des kollektivs der
ganzen gesellschaft aus dem wettbewerb
und viel kompromissen der einzelnen
individualinteressen herausbilden müssen
ein anstrengender und langwieriger
prozess der aber zu einer eher geringen
machtkonzentration führt kollektivismus
bedeutet vor allem dass schließlich
immer noch jemand ein einzelner führer
oder ein kleiner elitärer kreis der
mächtigen festwägen muss was denn die
interessen des staates dadurch auch
jedes einzelnen bürgers sein sollten und
die historische erfahrung hat gezeigt
dass es eben nicht unbedingt die
individuen mit den allerbesten
charaktereigenschaften sind welche sich
an die spitze der macht durch kämpfen
auch wenn sie so sanfte gesichtszüge die
vineta haben mögen aber lasst uns zum
thema rassismus zurückkehren denn wenn
euch zwangssterilisationen schon als
barbarischer menschenrechtsverletzungen
vor kommt hört euch mal diese zitat des
ehemaligen chinesischen
gesundheitsministers mal
geboten geringerer qualität sind wichtig
in den alten revolutionären basen bei
ethnischen minderheiten in grenzgebieten
und in wirtschaftlich marginalisierten
gebieten change an minister für
öffentliche gesundheit im jahr 1994
lasst euch noch mal auf der zunge
zergehen was dahinter man da eigentlich
gesagt hat denn seine aussage impliziert
ja das englische minderheiten gibt die
geburten geringerer qualität
hervorbringen
da stellt sich also ein politiker und
definiert welches leben qualitativ
lebenswert ist und welches nicht und das
mit in der praxis drastischen folgen
denn als konsequenz dieser ideologie
müssen vor allem die minderheiten am
meisten unter dem zwangssterilisationen
leiden zb ist es den tibetern zwar auf
dem papier erlaubt mehr als ein kind zu
bekommen
gleichzeitig werden aber auch sehr viele
paare dieser evis wohnen sich
sterilisieren zu lassen
da haben wir es also wieder viele der
chinesischen gesetze sind nichts als
feigenblätter hinter den ihr genaues
gegenteil eine brutal unmenschliche
agenda verborgen werden soll
es gab viele fälle in denen frauen
sterilisiert wurden ohne dass sie
überhaupt wussten welche operationen sie
sich unterziehen muss und wir sprechen
hier nicht von einzelfällen bleibt eine
studie der university of michigan hatten
sich allein im jahr 1995 mehr als drei
prozent also rund 100000 tibetische
frauen diesen operationen unterziehen
müssen und wenn ihr jetzt denkt dass das
schon ein schrecklicher zustand ist dann
haltet euch fest was jetzt kommt
in diesem land wird chinesisch
gesprochen wie wir schon mehrfach auf
diesen kanal erklärt haben steht ja
derzeitige chinesische staatspräsident
fidel bin für eine umkehr in allem was
in der von denk shopping im jahr 1978
eingeleiteten öffnung chinas zu tun
natürlich hat china seitdem einen
beachtlichen weg der öffnung gegenüber
der welt der moderne unter anerkennung
von bürgerrechten zurückgelegt wenn auch
in erster linie wirtschaftlich aber
shipping kam mit einer sehr klaren
vorstellung über den rechtlichen status
der ethnischen minderheiten was hat er
getan etwas was auf den ersten blick wie
eine gute nachricht klingen könnte er
hat die ein-kind-politik abgeschafft
china aber ende die ein kind politik und
erlaubt familien zwei kinder zu haben
dies bedeutet dass vor allem die herren
automatische mehr als ein kind promoter
bekommen können aber was ist mit dem
mitarbeiten
nun denkt shoppings sagte einmal den
berühmten satz das ist bei der mäusejagd
keine rolle spiele ob die katze schwarz
oder weiß sein
ich bin jedoch schert sich nicht mehr um
denkst weisheiten was der chinesische
präsident anstrebt ist genau das was die
präambel der chinesischen verfassung
verbietet die vereinheitlichung des
landes internet dominanz der hand kultur
diese wende war ein großer rückschlag
für die ethnischen minderheiten westlich
was sie die konsequenz einer lange zuvor
eingeleiteten salami taktik wie so oft
kommt die unterdrückung scheibchenweise
in baby schritten von denen keiner als
totaler bruch angesehen werden kann bis
es dann eben zu spät ist während also
das gesetz zur gesundheit von müttern
und kindern aus dem jahr 1994 den weg
für die sterilisation einiger
minderheiten endete begann skis
regierung und dänische politik auf
breiter front anzuwenden und die am
meisten betroffene gruppe waren die
uiguren
[Musik]
china reduziert geboten von uiguren mit
spiralen abtreibung und sterilisation
das alles ist perfekt instinkt super
nationalistische rhetorik für ihn ist
einheit sehr wichtig und wenn wir von
chinesischen nationalismus sprechen dann
meinen wir damit einen knallharten ein
partei nationalismus wie wir ihn aus den
dunkelsten epochen der europäischen
geschichte religionen müssen der
kommunistischen partei untergeordnet
sein sagt ina konkret bedeutet dies dass
die chinesischen kommunisten religion
zwar toleriert aber nur solange sie
selbst bestimmen können wer die
religiösen führer sind gleichschaltung
paar extras sehr gut konnten wir dies
bei der katholischen kirche beobachten
die in china verboten war
bis papst franziskus einen pakt mit
shipping schloss ein durch und durch
teuflischer die im grunde akzeptierte
china nämlich die autorität des vatikans
in glaubensfragen im austausch für
dessen diplomatische gefälligkeiten
andere religiöse minderheiten mit
weniger politischer handelsware haben
nicht so viel glück gehabt und genau das
ist der fall der uiguren das bulgarische
autonome gebiet xinjiang ist die einzige
region chinas in dem die uigurische
besiegt die uiguren sind ein turk volk
und früher hieß die gewichts auf mal ost
turkestan kann den achtzehnten
jahrhundert jedoch unter die herrschaft
der qing-dynastie welche sie in changing
umbenannte was zu deutsch übersetzt so
etwas wie neue provinz oder regionen ost
mark bedeutet ein hauptunterschied
zwischen uiguren und han-chinesen
besteht aber auch darin dass die uiguren
überwiegend muslimisch sind und die
arabische schrift halten denn diese
kulturelle unterschiede wurde die ganze
zeit in grund nicht angetastet
ohne ist die jetzige regierung in peking
lockt bereit alles zu tun um diese
kulturelle unterschiede einfach einmal
auszulöschen als erstes durch
gleichschaltung des bildungswesens im
jahr 2017 wurde der uigurischen
sprachunterricht in allen schulen in
deutschland verboten zwei jahre später
wurde die verwendung des arabischen
alphabets öffentlichen raum verboten
von außen betrachtet aus westlicher
perspektive könnte man das natürlich
leicht als kulturellen völkermord
bezeichnen aber die chinesische
regierung ist fest davon überzeugt
nichts unrechtes zu tun
aus ihrer sicht hält man diese gesetze
den uiguren bei der
migration okay sein der mal mega fair
und versuchen wir für einen moment die
sichtweise der kpc zu verstehen chinas
ansprache ist man dann wenn man sich
also perfekt in die chinesische
gesellschaft integrieren seine
karrierechancen maximieren und den
chinesischen traum nehmen will muss nun
als erstes die ansprache beherrschen
macht das sinn ja durchaus zumindest auf
den ersten blick mag es sogar wie eine
gute politik für die menschen erscheinen
china setzt alle mittel ein
damit die uiguren und chinesen werden
können als vollwertige chinesen wen
würde eine solche einladung zur
teilnahme am chinesischen traum an der
eine milliarde herrenrasse partie nicht
freuen endlich kein unter mensch mehr
sein müssen einfach super zu dumm nur
dass sich viele dieser undankbaren
uiguren gar nicht als minderwertige
unter menschen sehen aber keine sorge
das regime in peking schuld keine kosten
und mühen und hat auch für diese
renitenten integrationsverweigerer die
passenden methoden parat um sich
ausreichend zu motivieren deutscher
bericht prangert
menschenrechtsverletzungen chinas gegen
die kurdische muslime an
wir haben in deutschland hat eu
ratspräsidenten in diesen monaten und in
dieser position kommt deutschland eine
besondere verantwortung zu
die europäischen werte zu verteidigen
und und wert verteidigen und mit jeder
dass die immer menschenrecht
demokratische rechte bürgerrechte sehr
sehr deutlich und klar anzusprechen hier
fordern wir klartext vom deutschen
außenminister
diese menschenrechtsverletzungen sind an
ganz bestimmten ort bestand die peking
als umerziehungslager bezeichnet es wird
geschätzt dass es in der region shin
chan von mindestens 500 gibt offiziell
gibt es die wie der name schon sagt um
muslimische minderheiten um zu erziehen
und sie kulturell näher an die han
volksgruppe heranzuführen
angeblich hat sich und
berufsbildungszentrum und die
offiziellen fotos sehen aus wie die
titelseiten von sprach akademien eine
menge glücklicher junger studenten die
die kamera lächeln noch glücklicher als
die juden interessiert statt die frage
ist aber ob du dass die uiguren in
diesen lagern glücklich sind wir sind ja
ein wenig skeptisch denn die umerziehung
ist alles andere als eine freiwillige
prozess
du wirst beweise dafür sehen nun fangen
wir mal mit ein paar indizien an es ist
gut dokumentiert dass es in vielen
dieser zentren ganze arsenale von
tränengas elektroschockgeräte stellen
und vielen anderen essen und tixier
instrumenten gibt und wenn du jetzt
anwenden möchte ist dass dieses jahr
vielleicht auch nur zur berufsausbildung
von sicherheitskräften sowie dominas und
anderen bdsn experten dienen könnten
muss ich leider auch diese kindlich
naive illusion zerstören denn es gibt
mittlerweile eine ganze reihe von
figuren die es geschafft haben diesen
umerziehungslager zu entkommen und diese
prangern sie als ort der gänzlich von
freiwilligen folter gewalt und
misshandlungen an
aber es geht nicht nur darum was hinter
verschlossenen toren vorsichtig die
bereits eingangs sagte müssen die bruder
james den behörden eine reihe
biometrischer daten zur verfügung
stellen von fingerabdrücken bis hin zu
den abhoben etwas das im rest des landes
nicht in demselben maße geschieht
darüber hinaus ist china zunehmend
erfolgreiche entwicklung und
implementierung von gesichtserkennungs
technologie so dass wir innerhalb von
sekunden erkannt werden kann egal wo er
sich gerade aufhält und um das ist
vielleicht sagen was ist daran
rassistisch wenn diese technologie doch
überall in china eingesetzt wird
nun ja das ist ein gutes argument bis
man entdeckt dass 30 prozent aller
hierzu angefertigten klinische studien
speziell durch die analyse von und
burschen gesichtszügen durchgeführt
wurden und das ist schon verdammt
auffällig wenn man bedenkt dass die
uhren nun 0,76 prozent der gesamten
chinesischen bevölkerung ausmachen
an diesem punkt waren sich keiner von
euch also eher fragen die das alles den
chinesischen regime überhaupt durchgehen
kann ohne permanente proteststürme
sanktionen in aller welt in
demokratischen ländern und vor allem im
islamischen kulturraum nur die antwort
ist leider so simpel wie deprimierend
mit hilfe von geld und wirtschaftlicher
macht erst wer uns an der letzten tage
im amt hat sich der außenminister der
regierung trump mike pompeo dazu
durchgerungen und chinas politik
gegenüber den spuren zum genozid zu
erklären ob dies jedoch mehr als nur
eine alibi handlung war und dadurch
wirklich die neue regierung beiden in
die richtige richtung gelenkt werden
kann darf bezweifelt werden
wenn china bietet allen internationalen
mitläufern nicht nur wirtschaftliche
vorteile sondern auch ein bequemes paket
an argumenten mit denen sie kritiker in
ihren ländern beiseite wischen folgen
typischerweise bis die kpc drei
argumente um ihre handlungen zu
rechtfertigen argument nummer 1 ist
unser land mit euch nicht in unsere
inneren angelegenheiten ein
denn das würde euch ja auch nicht auch
wenn das gar nicht stimmt zweitens wir
versuchen nur islamischen terrorismus zu
bekämpfen
niebuhr und muslime sind muss sich daher
leicht radikalisieren können und
drittens wir hätten doch mit den armen
minder halten sich besser zu integrieren
und teil des großen chinesischen traums
werden zu können
wir haben vielleicht etwas falsche
methoden aber das alles dient ihrem
langfristigen wohlergehen natürlich
sehen dass die kurische und tibetische
bewegung ganz anders
exil-uiguren drängen auf gerichtsprozess
der china des völkermordes beschuldigt
hongkong china und tibet un experten
drängen pekings hartes durchgreifen an
peking ist sie außerdem noch auf die
gute alte teile und herrsche strategie
es bleibt sehr geschickt und weitgehend
unbemerkt perfide keile zwischen der
regierung der eu zwischen den parteien
in den usa zwischen dem westen und dem
islam und russland es ist die
korrelation von sich selbst super billig
in schlüsselindustrien einzukaufen und
dadurch die abhängigkeiten noch zu
erhöhen
und wer weiß vielleicht wird es uns
allen irgendwann nach und nach die ehre
erweisen und auch ins glückselige hahn
kollektiv integrieren zu dürfen so und
jetzt seid ihr an der reihe
wusstet ihr und dieser form des
chinesischen rassismus blockier dass
china mit seinem vorhaben die einheit im
ganzen land durchzusetzen um erfolgreich
sein wird welche anderen beispiele von
rassismus die in politik und medien
gerne unter den teppich gekehrt werden
kennt ihr seid uns bitte alles was euch
das reinfeldt in die kommentare
wenn du immer sind wir auf diese schon
sehr gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
video gefallen und vielleicht etwas
gebracht hat weiß ja gibt uns bitte
unterstützt uns in denen dieses video
mit euren freunden teilt der gäste nicht
dass wir jede woche neue videos
hochladen abonniert also unseren kanal
und klickt auf das ding so gewohnt um
rechtzeitig benachrichtigt zu werden als
gut und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]